Kailas with us in Richmond Virginia hi
Kayla
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi how
are you better than I deserve what's up
all right so I'm gonna kind of give you
a little bit of backstory of what
happened a year ago I was pregnant just
had my baby he was a high risk baby and
we had to go in and out of special
doctors and stuff like that well my
husband decided to take out a loan for
$2,400 so we can keep our place I went
ahead and called today to see exactly
how much we owe after paying one year of
306 dollars one year paying on it and we
owe $2,500 still on it I don't know what
to do and I cannot seem to get this debt
down is there a local office no okay
well I mean I would demand to know how
in the crap that happened you obviously
got in one of these ripoff finance
company loans it's 30% or something 149
percent interest rate after I've called
them and asked them exactly how much the
interest rate is oh I've never heard of
that how neat this is what happens when
you don't look at this is what happens
when you don't look at what you sign up
for so exactly yeah I mean I was just
trying to do the right thing no he
wasn't he was stupid
I mean who signs up for 249 percent
Interest that was dumb you know you have
to look at what you're doing you drive
your car in the ditch otherwise so go
get a credit card for 2,000 bucks and
pay this thing off with a credit card
and then we'll only be 18% and then take
three jobs and get on a budget and get
this mess cleaned up this is the Dave
Ramsey show